In this video I'll be giving an example
of a non-rational number. if the square
root of two were rational number then by
definition it must be expressed as the
ratio of two integers. If we then square
both sides we have two equals a squared
divided by B squared. If we multiply both
sides by b square root of 2 b
squared equals A squared and from this
we know that A squared is even. A squared
is even because we have two times some
integer which is B squared. Since A
squared is even, we know that is even
because a squared equals two times a
manager the integer I chose was 2k
squared that means that a times a can be
expressed as 2k x 2k which is to say
that A equals 2K. I can now substitute
2 x 2k squared or A squared and that
leaves us with B squared equals 2K
squared once these twos cancel out. Now, this also means that B squared is even
because b squared equals 2 times some
integer which is to say that B is also
even, following this same logic. Now we go back to our original premise the square
root of 2 equals A divided by B where a
divided by B is an irreducible fraction.
But since A is an even number and B is
also an even number we can express these
numbers as 2k and 2L. But these 2s
here will reduce meaning that will have
the square root of 2 equals K / L but
since this reduced since this is no
longer explicitly represented as A
divided by B and it reduced to
K / L we know that we do not have a
rational number. Now, there's a more
specific way to define these numbers or
classify these numbers but we need set
operators in the next video